A veces, siento que tengo un hechizo.
Por algo que sucedió antes de que yo naciera.
Verás. Hace mucho tiempo, existió una familia.
El papá era un gran músico.
Él y su familia cantaban, bailaban,
y agradecían lo qué tenían.
Pero también tenía un sueño: cantar para el mundo.
Y un día, se fue con su guitarra
y nunca volvió.
Y la mamá...
no tenía tiempo para llorar
por un músico abandonafamilias.
Luego de apartar toda la música de su vida
encontró un modo de mantener a su hija.
Puso manos a la obra
y aprendió a hacer zapatos.
Pudo hacer dulces, fuegos artificiales,
o ropa interior...
para luchadores.
Pero no, escogió zapatos.
Luego le enseñó a su hija
a hacer zapatos.
Y más tarde, le enseñó a su yerno.
Luego sus nietos siguieron sus pasos.
Y la familia creció igual que el negocio.
La música había dividido a su familia.
Pero los zapatos la mantenían unida.
Y esa mujer era
mi tatarabuela, Mamá Imelda.
Murió mucho antes que yo naciera.
Pero mi familia aún cuenta su historia
cada año en el Día de Los Muertos.
o día de muertos como le decimos aquí.
Y su hijita
es mi bisabuela, Mamá Coco.
Hola, Mamá Coco.
¿Cómo estás, Julio?
En realidad, me llamo Miguel.
A Mamá Coco
le cuesta trabajo recordar cosas.
Pero aun así me gusta hablar con ella.
Yo le cuento prácticamente todo.
Antes corría así. Pero ahora corro así
y soy más veloz.
¡Y la ganadora es Luchadora Coco!
Aquí sí ves un hoyito,
pero no de este lado.
Se ve, no se ve. Se ve, no se ve.
Miguel, no estás comiendo.
Mi abuelita,
es la hija de Mamá Coco.
Uy estás flaco, mijo.
Hay que comer más.
No, gracias.
Yo dije, ¿vas a querer más tamales?
Sí?
¡Eso es lo que creí escuchar!
Mi abuelita dirige la casa
tal como lo hacía Mamá Imelda.
¡Sin música!
- Y aunque la vida
- ¡Sin música!
Creo que somos la única familia
en México que odia la música.
Y a mi familia no le molesta.
Pero yo...
- Vuelva para comer, mijo.
- Te quiero, mamá.
¡No soy como el resto de mi familia!
- Hola, Miguel!
- Hola!
- Muchas gracias.
- De nada, Miguel.
¡Dante!
Sentado. Al suelo. Da una vuelta. Saluda.
¡Chocalas!
¡Bien, Dante!
Sé que no debería amar la música.
¡Pero no es mi culpa! ¡Es suya!
Ernesto de la Cruz.
El mejor músico de todos los tiempos.
En esta misma plaza, el joven Ernesto de la Cruz
dio sus primeros pasos...
para volverse el más amado cantante
en la historia de México.
Empezó como un completo don nadie
de Santa Cecilia, como yo.
Pero cuando tocaba su música,
hacía que la gente se enamorara de él.
Salía en películas.
¡Tenía una guitarra increíble!
¡Podía volar!
Y escribió las mejores canciones.
Pero mi favorita es...
- Recuérdame
Hoy me tengo que ir mi amor
No llores por favor
Te llevo en mi corazón
Y cerca me tendrás
A solas yo te cantaré
Soñando en regresar
Recuérdame
Aunque tengo que emigrar
- Recuérdame
Si mi guitarra oyes llorar
Ella con su triste canto te acompañará
Hasta que en mis brazos tú estés
Vivió la clase de vida con la que uno sueña.
Hasta 1942.
Cuando lo aplastó
una campana gigante.
Quiero ser igualito a él.
A veces, miro a de la Cruz y tengo la sensación
de que algo nos conecta.
Siento que si él pudo tocar música,
tal vez un día, yo también.
Si no fuera por mi familia.
Ay-ay-ay, muchacho.
Solo pedí una boleada
no la historia de tu vida.
Sí. Lo siento.
Es que cuando estoy en casa no puedo decir
nada de esto. Y...
Oye, si fuera tú,
yo enfrentaría a mi familia y diría...
"Eh, soy un músico.
¡Les guste o no!"
- Eso jamás lo diría.
- Tú sí eres un músico, ¿no?
No lo sé. La verdad, yo toco para mí solamente.
¡Ah! ¿De la Cruz se volvió el mejor músico
del mundo por esconder su talentazo?
¡No! Él salió directo a esa plaza
y empezó a tocar.
Ay mira mira, ¡se preparan para hoy!
El concurso de música
del Día de Muertos.
¿Quieres ser como tu héroe?
¡Inscríbete!
¡Mi familia se pondría loca!
Si te da miedo hacerlo,
entonces, zapatero a tus zapatos.
A ver, ¿qué era lo que
de la Cruz siempre decía?
¿Vive tu momento?
Muéstrame lo que haces, muchacho.
Tu público seré yo.
¡Miguel!
- ¡Abuelita!
- ¿Qué estás haciendo aquí?
Deja en paz a mi nieto.
Doña, ¡cálmese!
Quería una lustrada y ya.
Conozco tus trucos, mariachi.
¿Qué cosa te dijo?
Solo quiso enseñarme su guitarra.
¡Atrevido!
Mi nieto es un lindo y dulce angelito,
chiquito cielito.
Sin nada que ver con tu música,
mariachi. ¡No lo vuelvas a molestar!
Ay, pobrecito. O, ¿estás bien, mijo?
¡Yo te advertí de que no vinieras a esta plaza!
Ahora ven a casa. ¡Ya!
¿Cuántas veces te lo hemos dicho?
Esa plaza está llena de mariachis.
Sí, tío Berto.
- ¡No, no, no, no, no!
- ¡Ay! ¡Zacate fuchi!
Solo es Dante.
Sí bautizas a un perro de la calle
te va a seguir por siempre. Ahora, traeme mi chancla.
Encontré a su hijo
en la Plaza del Mariachi.
¡Ay, Miguel!
Ya sabes lo que abuelita
piensa sobre la plaza.
- Solo lustró los zapatos.
- ¡De un músico de hecho!
Pero la plaza es dónde
la gente camina.
Si abuelita dice no más plaza,
se acabó la plaza.
- ¿Pero tampoco esta noche?
- ¿Qué hay esta noche?
Bueno... ahí habrá un show de talentos
y así que pensé...
- ¿... en inscribirte?
- Pues, ¿tal vez?
Necisitas talento para un show de talentos.
¿Y qué es lo que harás tú? ¿Lustrar zapatos?
Es Día de Muertos.
Todos se quedan aquí hoy.
Solo importa la familia.
A la ofrenda. Vámonos.
No, no pongas esos ojos.
El Día de Muertos es la única noche del año
en que nuestros ancestros nos visitan.
Ponemos sus fotos en la ofrenda
para que sus espíritus crucen de vuelta.
Eso es muy importante.
Si no las ponemos, ellos no cruzarán.
Preparamos esta comida, y dejamos
cosas que amaron en vida, mijo.
Y todo es para que la familia se reúna.
Y no quiero que te salgas
a no sé dónde. ¿Adónde vas?
Creí que era todo.
Ay, este muchacho. Ser parte de esta familia
implica apoyar siempre a esta familia.
- No quiero verte termines igual que...
- ¿El papá de Mamá Coco?
¡Nunca menciones a ese hombre!
Es mejor olvidarlo.
Pero tú eres la que...
Yo solo...
Pero... yo...
¿Papá? ¿Papá regresó al fin?
Mamá, cálmese, cálmese.
¿Papá ya vino?
No, mamá. Aquí estoy. Cálmese.
¿Quién eres tú?
Descanse, mamá.
Soy un poco dura
porque te quiero, Miguel. ¿Miguel?
Ya no sé qué hacer con este muchacho.
Tienen razón. Eso es lo que necesita.
Eres tú. Entra ya. Ven, Dante, ¡rápido!
Harás que me meta en problemas.
Alguien podría oírme.
Solo quiero que alguien me escuche.
No solo tú. ¡Quieto!
¡Perfecto!
Tengo que cantar. Y tocar también.
La música es, no solo está en mí,
es lo que soy.
Cuando la vida me golpea,
toco mi guitarra.
El resto del mundo obedece las reglas,
pero yo obedezco de corazón.
¿Nunca has sentido que hay
una canción en el aire y...
¿solamente toca para ti?
Cerca está el amor
Ya se siente su encanto
Nunca creí que algo así
Iba a llegar para mí
No pierdas la fe, hermana.
Pero, padre, él nunca escuchará.
Él escuchará. ¡Con música!
Una canción, una canción
Llega hasta el corazón
Nunca subestimes
el poder de la música.
Pero mi padre nunca otorgará su permiso.
Ya no voy a pedir permiso.
Cuando llega tu momento,
no puedes dejar que se vaya.
¡Tienes que vivirlo!
Señor de la Cruz, ¿qué se requirió
para que usted viviera su momento?
Tuve que tener fe en mi sueño.
Nadie vendría a entregármelo.
Dependía de mí alcanzar ese sueño
- capturarlo y ver que se cumpliera.
- ...y ver que se cumpliera.
Ya no me voy a esconder, Dante.
¡Tengo que vivir mi momento!
Debo tocar en la Plaza del Mariachi
aunque me cueste la vida.
¡El Día de Muertos ya comienza!
No no no no no. Tenemos que señalar el camino.
Los pétalos guían a los ancestros a casa.
¡Mamá! ¿Dónde ponemos esta mesa?
En el patio, mijos.
- ¿Junta a la cocina?
- Sí. Déjala ... la otra.
- ¡Escógete, escógete!
- ¿Miguel?
¡Nada! Mamá, papá. Yo...
Miguel, tu abuelita
tuvo la más maravillosa idea.
Ya fue decidido.
Es tiempo de que te nos unas en el taller.
- ¿Qué?
- La boleada quedó atrás, hijo.
Fabricarás zapatos,
a diario después de la escuela.
¡Oh! Nuestro Miguelitititito continuará
la tradición familiar.
¡Y en el Día de Muertos!
Tus ancestros se sentirán orgullosos.
Harás huaraches como tu tía Victoria.
Y puntas de ala como tu Papá Julio.
¿Pero si no puedo hacer zapatos como ustedes?
Ay, Miguel.
Tienes a tu familia para guiarte.
Tú eres un Rivera. Y un Rivera es...
Un zapatero. Hasta los huesos.
¡Ese es mi muchacho! ¡Berto!
Abre el mejor botella.
Quiero hacer un brindis.
¡Dante! No, Dante. ¡Quieto!
¡No, no! No.
¿La guitarra de de la Cruz?
Mamá Coco,
¿Tu papá es Ernesto de la Cruz?
¡Papá! ¡Es él!
Sé quién fue mi tatarabuelito.
Miguel, qué haces, bájate.
¡El papá de Mamá Coco
fue Ernesto de la Cruz!
- ¿Hijo de qué estás hablando?
- ¡Voy a ser músico!
¿Qué es todo esto?
¿Guardas secretos como éste de tu familia?
Esto es el tiempo
que pasa en la plaza.
- Piensas solo en locas fantasías.
- No es una fantasía.
¡Este hombre era Ernesto de la Cruz!
¡El mejor músico de todos los tiempos!
¡Jamás oímos nada sobre este hombre!
Pero, como sean,
el señor abandonó a su familia.
No es futuro para mi hijo.
Pero, papá, tú dijiste
que mi familia iba a guiarme.
Bueno, de la Cruz es mi familia.
La música está en mis venas.
¡Jamás! Su música fue una desgracia,
no voy a tolerarlo.
- Si me dejaran...
- Miguel...
Haz caso a tu familia.
No más música.
- ¡Solo escuchen como toco!
- No discutas más.
¿Quieres terminar
como ese hombre? ¿Olvidado?
¿y fuera de la ofrenda de tu familia?
Me da igual si me ponen en su absurda ofrenda.
¡No!
Listo. Sin guitarra.
No hay música.
Te vas a sentir mejor
después de cenar con tu familia.
¡No quiero ser parte de esta familia!
¡Miguel!
Quiero tocar en la plaza, igual del
de la Cruz. ¿Tienen lugar todavía?
¿Tienes un instrumento?
No. Pero si me prestan
una guitarra...
Los músicos deben traer
sus instrumentos.
Tú, busca una guitarra, ¿sí?
y te pongo en la lista.
- Disculpe, ¿quiere prestarme su guitarra?
- Lo siento, muchacho.
- ¿no le sobra una guitarra?
- No.
- Necesito una guitarra solo por un ratito.
- Ahora no, niño.
Tatarabuelo, ¿qué más puedo hacer?
No, no. Dante, ¡ya! ¡Cállate!
Ay, perdón.
Señor de la Cruz, por favor,
no te enojes. Soy Miguel.
Tu tataranieto.
Necesito tomar éste.
Nuestra familia no comprende lo que siento.
Es que la música no les gusta pero...
yo sé que tú entenderías.
Habías dicho que obedeciera mi corazón
que viviera mi momento.
Así que si no te molesta,
voy a tocar en la plaza. ¡Como tú lo hacías!
¡La guitarra!
¡Alguien robó la guitarra de de la Cruz!
La ventana está rota. ¡Miren!
A ver, ¿quién está ahí?
Discúlpeme. No es lo que cree.
De la Cruz es mi...
Aquí no hay nadie.
Miguel, ven a casa.
Miguel, ¿dónde estás?
¡Uy, qué horror! Ay pequeño. ¿Estás bien?
Ven. Déjame ayudarte.
Gracias. Yo...
¿Qué te pasa?
Está más grande cada día.
¡Dante!
¿Tú sí me ves? ¡No corras!
Ay ¿Qué tienes? ¡Dante!
Ay, perdón. Lo lamento
¿Miguel?
-¿Miguel?
¿Estás aquí? ¿Aquí, aquí?
¿Y puedes vernos?
¡Nuestro Miguelitititito!
Dime de dónde te conozco.
Somos tu familia, mijo.
- Tía Rosita?
- Sí.
- Papá Julio?
- Hola.
Tía Victoria?
No creo que esté muerto del todo.
Y no está con vida del todo.
¡Hay que decirle a mamá Imelda,
ella lo resolverá!
¡Oigan! Es Mamá Imelda.
No logró cruzar.
- ¡Se atoró!
- ¡En el otro lado!
¿Tío Oscar? ¿Tío Felipe?
Ah. Hola, Miguel.
Algo me dice que tienes que ver con todo esto...
Pero si Mamá Imelda
ya no vendrá aquí...
Entonces iremos por ella. ¡Vámonos!
Sube, Miguel. No te asustes.
¿Dante? ¡Dante! Dante, ¡espera!
Quédate conmigo, amigo.
Yo ne sé... dónde...
No es un sueño, ¿verdad?
¿En serio siguen aquí?
- ¿Creías que no era así?
- Pues no sé.
Creí que era una de esas mentiras
que los adultos les dicen a los niños.
- Como las vitaminas.
- Miguel, las vitaminas sí son reales.
Ahora pienso que tal vez sí.
Mija, no mires así a...
Esos son...
¡Alebrijes! Pero esos son...
Alebrijes reales.
Criaturas espirituales.
Guían a las almas en su viaje.
Mira dónde pisas.
Lluevan caquitas por todos lados.
¡Bienvenidos a la Tierra de los Muertos!
Mantengan sus ofrendas
a la mano para el reingreso.
Bienvenido. ¿Algo que declarar?
Churros. De mi familia.
¡Qué maravilloso!
Sí tiene algún problema con su viaje, hay agentes
del departamento...
de reuniones familiares listos para atenderlos.
Siguiente familia, por favor.
Su hijo puso sus fotos en la ofrenda.
¡Disfruten su visita!
Y no olviden volver antes del amanecer.
Disfruten su visita.
¿Siguiente? Su foto está en la ofrenda
de su dentista. Disfrute su visita.
- Gracias.
- ¿Siguiente?
¡Sí sí! Soy yo, Frida Kahlo.
¿Nos saltamos el escaneo?
Aparezco en mil ofrendas
y no quiero sobrecargar su aparatito.
Ay ¡qué pena! Creo que nadie puso tu foto, Frida.
OK, cuando dije que era Frida, justo ahora,
yo, eh, la engañé.
Y siento mucho haberlo hecho.
Sin foto en una ofrenda, no cruzas el puente.
¿Sabes qué? Subiré de todos modos, ¿está bien?
no notarán que me fui.
¡Oye!
Voy a llegar... Solo un poco más.
Arriba, compadre...
Bien. Claro. Me da igual.
¡Tonto puente de flores!
No sé qué haría yo
si nadie pusiera mi foto.
- ¿Siguiente?
- Ven, mijo. Ya nos toca.
Bienvenidos, amigos.
¿Algo que declarar?
Eh... ya que lo pregunta, pues, algo...
Llamando a Marta Gonzales Ramos.
Repórtese al Nivel Siete.
¡Cómo extraño mi nariz!
Tiene que ayudarnos, amigo. Hay que llegar
a doce ofrendas hoy.
¡Nene no va a visitar a la familia
de tu ex esposa por el Día de Muertos!
¡Exijo hablar con la persona a cargo!
Perdón, señora,
aquí dice que nadie puso su foto.
Mi familia siempre, siempre pone mi foto
en la ofrenda.
¡Esa chatarra solo dice mentiras!
- Mamá Imelda?
- Ay, mi familia!
No quieren dejarme cruzar el puente.
Díganle a esta mujer y a su horrible máquina,
que mi foto, ¡sí esta en la ofrenda!
Bueno, es que nunca llegamos a la ofrenda.
- ¿Qué?
- Antes nos encontramos a...
- ¿Miguel?
- Mamá Imelda.
¿Qué sucede aquí?
¿Son la familia Rivera?
- Están hechizados.
- ¿Qué?
El Día de Muertos es cuando se da algo
a los muertos. No se les quitan los muertos.
- Pero, yo no robé esa guitarra.
- ¿Guitarra?
Era de mi tatarabuelo.
a él le hubiera hecho feliz dármela.
¡Ah ah ah! Aquí nadie habla de ese músico.
Está muerto para la familia.
... también ustedes están muertos.
Ay perdón. ¿El alebrije de quién es?
Solo es Dante.
La verdad no sé si sea un alebrije.
Parece un perro común y corriente.
O una salchicha que pasó con una barbería.
Sea lo que sea, soy...
terriblemente alérgico.
Pero Dante no tiene ningun pelo, señor.
Y ya no tengo nariz, niño.
Así son las cosas.
Pero nada de esto explica
por qué no yo no crucé esta vez.
¡Oh!
¿Quitaste mi foto de la ofrenda?
- ¡Fue un accidente!
- ¿Cómo lo regresamos?
Bueno, ese era una falta familiar...
deshacer un hechizo familiar requiere
hacer que tu familia te bendiga.
¿Eso ya?
Si tu familia te bendice
lo demás bien debería volverás a normal.
Pero hazlo antes del amanecer.
¿y al amanecer qué sucede?
¡Híjole! ¡Tu dedo!
Uy, Miguel,
no puedes desmayarte ahora.
Pero no temas. Tu familia está aquí.
Te da la bendición aquí ahora.
Cempasúchil, cempasúchil.
¡Aja! Perdón, señora.
Ahora justo a mira al vivo y diga su nombre.
Miguel.
Justo ese.
Ahora diga: "Te otorgo mi bendición".
Te otorgo mi bendición.
Te otorgo mi bendición
para ir a casa...
poner mi foto de vuelta en la ofrenda,
y no volver a tocar música nunca.
¿Qué? ¡Oiga, no es justo!
Ella tiene derecha de agregar
la condición que desea.
- Bien.
- Ahora dale el pétalo a Miguel.
¡No hay esqueletos!
Plaza del Mariachi, ahí voy.
Solo dos segundos
y ya rompiste tu promesa.
Esto no es justo. Es mi vida.
Tú ya tuviste la tuya.
Papá Julio, dame tu bendición.
¿Tía Rosita? ¿Oscar?
¿Felipe? ¿Tía Victoria?
No lo hagas más difícil, mijo. Regresas
a mi manera, o no regresas.
¿Odias la música de ese modo?
No voy a dejar que siga
la misma ruta que él.
La misma ruta que él...
Es de la familia.
- Escucha a Mamá Imelda.
- Solo quiere cuidarte, muchacho.
Sé razonable.
Con permiso, tengo que ir al baño.
Se vuelvo.
¿y si le decimos que no hay baños
en la Tierra de los Muertos?
Tenemos una familia
que busca a un ninõ vivo...
Si quiero ser un músico,
buscaré la bendición de un músico.
Voy a encontrar a mi tatarabuelo.
Quieto ahí, muchacho.
¡Estoy viendo al niño vivo!
Discúlpen. Discúlpen, amigos.
Disculpen.
No. ¡Dante!
Perturbar la paz. Escapar de un oficial.
Falsificar una uniceja.
- ¿Eso es ilegal?
- Muy ilegal.
Necesitas reformarte, amigo.
¿Amigo? Es lindo oírte decir eso porque...
he tenido un duro Día de Muertos
y necesito un amigo justo ahora.
Y los amigos tratan bien a sus amigos.
Escucha. Ayúdame a cruzar el puente esta noche,
y yo voy a compensarte.
¿Te gusta de la Cruz?
Nosotros somos viejos amigos.
Te doy boletos hasta el frente de
su Amanecer Espectacular.
¡Te llevo backstage!
¡Te le presento!
¡Solo déjame cruzar el puente!
Te debería encerrar
por el resto de la fiesta.
Pero mi turno ya va a terminar,
y quiero visitar a mi familia viva.
Te voy a dejar con una advertencia.
- ¿Regresas al menos mi disfraz?
- No.
... buen amigo
¡Oye! ¿Tú conoces a de la Cruz?
¿Quién quiere...? ¡Ay! ¡Estás vivo!
Sí, estoy vivo. Y solo puedo volver
a la Tierra de los Vivos...
si de la Cruz me bendice.
Extrañamente específico.
Él es mi tatarabuelo.
Es tu tatara... ¿qué?
Oye, oye, oye, oye, oye. Oye, oye.
Bueno... a ver, a ver.
¡Sí! ¡Irás de vuelta
a la Tierra de los Vivos!
Aunque creo que tal vez no sea una gran idea.
¡No, niño! Yo te ayudo, amigo.
Y luego tú a mí.
Nos ayudamos el uno al otro.
Pero más importante, ¡tú a mí!
- ¡Miguel!
- Soy Héctor.
Qué gusto
Espérame, chamaco!
Ay, ¡ese niño hará que lo maten!
Quiero a mi guía espiritual... Pepita.
¿Quién trae el pétalo que Miguel tocó?
Yo... Lindo Alebrije...
Quieto... Arriba... Mira arriba.
A ver, a ver. Arriba, más, más.
OK... y... ¡ta-da!
Todo un cadáver.
Escucha, Miguel, en este mundo,
los recuerdos mueven todo.
Si te recuerdan muy bien,
siempre ponen tu foto...
y dejan cruzar el puente y visitar a los vivos
el Día de Muertos... aunque no a mí
¿Tú no has cruzado jamás?
Nadie jamás pone mi foto.
¡Pero tú arreglarás eso!
¿Este es tú?
Eh, muy guapo, eh?
Entonces, tú me llevas con mi tatarabuelo...
¿y yo pongo tu foto
cuando regrese?
¡Exacto, mi amigo! ¡Sí!
Gran idea, ¡sí! Un detalle.
De la Cruz no es tan fácil contactar,
y tengo que cruzar el puente ahora.
Esta noche. ¿No tendrás otro familiar aquí cerca?
¿Alguien un poco más accesible?
No.
No te hagas el occiso, chamaco.
Tienes que tener más familia.
Solo de la Cruz.
Si to no me ayudas, lo busco yo mismo.
OK, tú ganas. Bien, bien.
Te llevo con tu tatarabuelo.
No va a ser fácil, niño.
Él es un hombre ocupado. ¿Qué estás haciendo?
Camino igual que un esqueleto.
Para ser igual.
No. Los esqueletos no caminan así.
- Así lo haz esto.
- No es cierto. ¡Ya basta!
El Amanecer Espectacular
de Ernesto de la Cruz. ¡Qué padre!
Cada año tu tatarabuelo
presenta un bobo show...
que marque el fin del Día de Muertos.
¡Y tú tienes entradas!
¡Ya dijiste que eran la primera fila!
Eso... no era cierto.
De verdad, lo lamento.
Tranquilo, chamaco.
Ven, yo te llevo con él.
¿Y cómo?
Yo sé exactamento dónde está ensayando.
Espero que traigas mi vestido, Héctor.
- Hola.
- Ceci, ya no lo tengo.
- ¡Yo lo sabía! Tengo que vestir a 40 bailarinas para el amanecer.
- Ceci, lo sé, Ceci...
Y gracias a ti, ¡me falta
una Frida para el número de apertura!
¡Dante! Aquí no se puede entrar.
¡Dante! ¡Ven acá!
¡Tú! ¿Quién te dejó entrar aquí?
- Solo por seguir a mi...
- ¡Oh! ¡El poderoso Xoloitzcuintli!
Guía de los espíritus deambulantes.
¿Qué espíritu habrás guiado hasta mí?
No creo que sea un guía espiritual, señora.
Los alebrijes de este mundo
adquieren muchas formas.
Son misteriosos al igual que poderosos.
O tal vez sea un perro y ya...
Ven, usaré tus ojos.
Tú eres el público. Oscuridad.
Y emerge de la oscuridad, una gigantesca papaya.
Las bailarinas brotan de la papaya,
y cada una soy yo.
Todas beben la leche
de su madre, que es un cactus.
Pero que también soy yo.
Y su leche no es leche, son lágrimas.
¿Crees que es obvio?
Creo que es ¿adecuadamente obvio?
Necesita música.
Uy, ¿qué te parece un...?
¡Uy! Y qué tal un...
¿Y qué tal si todo estuviera en llamas?
¡Sí! ¡Fuego en todas partes!
¡Inspirado! Tú tienes el espíritu de un artista.
Las bailarinas salen.
La música baja, las luces se apagan.
¡Y Ernesto de la Cruz
se alza en el escenario!
¿Eh?
Canta un par de canciones, el sol sale,
aplauden todos...
Disculpa, ¿y el verdadero de la Cruz?
¡Ernesto no necesita ensayar!
Está ocupado ofreciéndo su elegante
fiesta en la cima de su torre.
Chamaco, no te alejes de mí así.
Ya ven, no molestes a las celebridades.
¡Dijiste que mi tatarabuelo vendría aquí!
Está del otro lado en una súper fiesta.
Ese flojo. Si es su show
¿por qué no está ensayando?
Si son tan grandes amigos,
¿entonces por qué no te invitó?
Él es tu tatarabuelo,
¿a tí por qué no te invitó?
¡Eh, Gustavo!
¿Oíste algo sobre esta fiesta?
¡Sí es toda una gala!
Pero si no fuiste invitado,
nunca podrás entrar, Chorizo.
¡Es Chorizo! ¡Choricito!
- Ajá. Muy simpático, todos, ....
- ¿Chorizo?
¡Él es famoso! Oye, oye, cómo moriste, cuéntame.
Ahora no quiero hablar.
¡Se ahogó comiendo chorizo!
No es cierto, ¿OK? Lo que comí me intoxicó.
¡Eso es muy diferente!
Y por eso digo los músicos
¡montón de presumidos tontos!
- ¡También soy músico!
- ¿Lo eres?
Bueno, si de verdad quieres encontrar a Ernesto,
está la competencia de música...
en la Plaza de la Cruz.
El ganador se presenta en su fiesta.
No. Chamaco, estás loco si piensas...
Necesito que mi tatarabuelo me bendiga.
¿Dónde consigo una guitarra?
Conozco a alguien.
¿Está por aquí, Pepita?
¿Hallaste a nuestro muchacho?
- ¡Una huella!
- Es una bota Rivera.
- ¡Talla 25!
- Y medio.
- Pronador.
- Miguel.
¿Y por qué tantas ganas de volverte músico?
¡Porque mi tatarabuelo fue músico!
... ¿que vivía actuando como un mono
entre personas que jamás conoció?
No, gracias. ¡No!
¿Qué entiendes? Oye,
¿dónde vas a conseguir esa guitarra?
Estamos cerca.
Ya basta, chamaco, ¡camina!
- ¡Primo Héctor!
- ¡Hola, todos! ¡Eh, tío!
- ¿Qué onda?
- ¿Estas personas son tu familia?
En cierto modo. Somos
los que no tienen fotos ni ofrendas.
Sin familia la cual visitar.
Casi olvidados, ¿entiendes?
Así que nos gusta decirnos primo, o tío, o lo que sea.
- Héctor!
- Tía Chelo!
Ay, muchas gracias.
¡Guárdenme un poco!
¿Y dónde está Chicharrón?
Está en el jacal. No sé si esté
de humor para visitas.
¿Quién no quiere una visita del primo Héctor?
Buenas noches, Chicharrón!
Aleja tu cara insoportable, Héctor.
Anímate, es Día de Muertos.
Te traje una ofrendita.
- ¡Lárgate de aquí!
- Ay, lo haría, Chich.
Pero la cosa es que,
mi buen amigo Miguel...
necesita que prestes tu guitarra.
- ¿Mi guitarra?
- Sí.
- ¿Mi amada y preciosa guitarra?
- Prometo devolverla de inmediato.
¿Igual que prometiste devolver
mi camioneta? ¿O mi minibar?
- Ay, es que...
- ¿O mis servilletas?
¿Mi lazo? ¿Mi fémur?
- No, no igual que esas veces.
- Quiero mi fémur, tú...
- ¿Estás bien, amigo?
- Desaparezco, Héctor.
Ya lo puedo sentir. Aunque quisiera
no podría tocar otra vez esa cosa.
Toca, para mí...
No, no. Yo dejé esa hace mucho tiempo, Chich.
La guitarra es para el niño.
Si la quieres, tienes que ganártela.
¡Ay! Solo por ti, amigo.
¿Cuál quieres oír?
Conoces mi favorita, Héctor.
Conoces ya a Juanita
Sus ojos son bicolores
Sus dientes chuecos
Y tiene tres
Con sus...
uñas el suelo rayó
- Eso no es la letra.
- Hay niños presentes.
Sus trenzas son de alambre
Arqueadas sus piernas están
Si yo no fuera tan feo
Su amor tal vez me podría dar
Me mueve mis recuerdos.
Gracias.
Oye. ¿Qué le pasó?
Ya fue olvidado.
Si no queda nadie que te recuerda
en el Mundo de los Vivos...
desapareces de este mundo.
Lo dicen la muerte final.
y ¿dónde está, ahora?
Nadie lo sabe.
Pero acaba de conocerme.
Cuando yo vuelva nunca lo olvidaré.
No, esto no funciona así, chamaco.
Nuestra memoria, solo se puede transmitir
por los que nos conocieron en vida...
en las historias que cuentan sobre nosotros.
Pero no hay nadie con vida
que pueda contar las historias de Chich.
Nos pasa a todos al final.
Ven, de la Cruzito,
tienes un concurso que ganar.
Dijiste que odias a los músicos.
Jamás dijiste que fuiste uno.
¿Por qué crees que conozco
a tu tatarabuelo?
Tocábamos música juntos.
Lo que sabe le enseñé yo.
¡No inventes!
¿Tocabas con Ernesto de la Cruz...
el mejor músico de todos los tiempos?
¡Qué simpático! Las cejas
más grandes de la historia tal vez.
¿Pero su música? No es tan buena.
No tienes idea de que hablas.
¡Bienvenido a la Plaza de la Cruz!
¡A escena, chamaco!
¡Llévelo! ¡Camisetas! ¡Cabezones!
¡Bienvenidos a todos!
¿Quién está listo para algo de música?
Es una batalla de las bandas, amigos.
El ganador se presenta ante el maestro
en persona, Ernesto de la Cruz...
¡en su fiesta de esta noche!
Nuestra entrada, muchacho.
¡Que la competencia comience!
¿Cuál es el plan?
¿Qué vas a interpretar?
Mi favorita, Recuérdame.
- ¡No! Esa no. No.
- ¿Por qué no? ¡Es la más popular de todas!
Demasiado popular.
Recuérdame
Aunque tenga que emigrar
- Recuérdame
- No llores por favor
- ¿Qué opinas de Un Poco Loco?
- ¡Epa! ¡Esa sí es una canción!
¿De la Cruzito? Tú sigues después.
Los Chachalacos, ya les toca.
¡Los Chachalacos!
¿Te pones nervioso siempre que presentas?
No lo sé. Este es mi primera presentación.
¿Qué? ¡Dijiste que eras músico!
¡Sí soy! Al menos, lo seré pronto.
- ¡Oy!
- Cuando gane.
¿Ese es tu plan? No. Tienes que ganar, Miguel.
Tu vida literalmente depende...
de que ganes. ¡Y jamás has actuado
en público!  Yo subo.
- ¡No! Yo tengo que hacerlo.
- ¿Por qué?
Si no puedo tocar al menos una canción,
¿de qué derecho me llamaré músico?
¿Y eso qué importa?
Porque no solo quiero
que de la Cruz me bendiga...
yo quiero probar que lo merezco también.
¡Qué tierno y dulce ese sentimiento!
¡Justo en la peor ocasión!
¡OK! ¿Quieres subir ahí?
Entonces ¡demuéstralo!
Primero a relajar el cuerpo,
deja ir esos nervios, sácalos afuera.
Ahora dame tu mejor grito.
- ¿Mi mejor grito?
- Ya sabes. ¡Grita! Fuerte y claro.
¡Qué bien se siente! OK, ahora, hazlo tú.
Ay, no me hagas esto.
De la Cruzito, ¡te toca!
Miguel, mírame. Oye, oye, mírame.
Ya lograrás.
Atrapa su atención y no la dejes ir.
Harás bien, chamaco.
¡De la Cruzito!
¿Por qué no toca? ¿Qué le pasa?
¡Que regresen los perros que cantan!
Que el cielo no es azul
Ay mi amor, ay mi amor
Que es rojo dices tú
Ves todo al revés
Ay mi amor, ay mi amor
Creo que piensas con los pies
Tú me traes un poco loco
Un poqui-ti-ti-to loco
Estoy adivinando
Qué quieres y pa' cuando
Y así estoy celebrando
Que me he vuelto un poco loco
¡No! ¡No!
- ¡Nada mal para un esqueleto!
- ¡Tú también eres grande, gordito! ¡Eso!
¡Está cerca! ¡Búsquenlo!
Chiflado tú me vuelves
Y eso está un poco loco
Tu mente que despega
Tú siempre con ideas
Con mi cabeza juegas
Todo es un poco loco
- Buscamos a un niño vivo, señor
- ¿Como de 12?
¿Han visto a un niño vivo?
Un poqui-ti-ti-ti-ti-ti
Ti-ti-ti-ti-ti-ti-ti-ti-to loco
¡Eh! ¡Lo lograste!
¡Estoy muy orgulloso! ¡Eso!
¡Otra! ¡Otra! ¡Otra!
- ¡Eh! ¿Ahora qué haces?
- ¡Hay que salir de aquí!
¿Qué? ¿Estás loco?
Estamos a punto de ganar.
Damas y caballeros,
tengo que dar un aviso de emergencia.
Por favor ayuden a encontrar un niño
vivo. Responde al nombre de Miguel.
Hace unas horas se escapó de su familia.
Solo quieren enviarlo de vuelta
a la Tierra de los Vivos.
Oye, oye, oye. Dijiste que de la Cruz
era tu única familiar.
La única persona que se le regresaría.
Sí tengo otra familia, pero...
¿Pudiste llevarte mi foto todo esto tiempo?
¡Pero odian la música!
Necesito la bendición de un músico.
- ¡Dijiste mentiras!
- O, y tú nunca lo haces.
Mírame. Me están olvidando, Miguel.
Ni siquiera sé si pasaré la noche.
No voy a perder mi oportunidad
de cruzar el puente porque...
tú quieres vivir una absurda fantasía musical.
- ¡No es absurda!
- Te voy a entregar a tu familia.
- ¡Suéltame!
- Luego me lo agradecerás.
No quieres ayudarme.
Quieres salvarte a ti mismo.
Toma tu fea foto. ¡Aléjate de mí!
¡No!
¡Chamaco! ¿Dónde estás?
¡Chamaco! ¡Uy! ¡Espera!
Dante, ¡cállate! ¡No! Dante, ya basta.
No quiere ayudarme. ¡Dante! ¡Que no!
¡Ya basta! ¡Déjame solo!
No eres un guía espiritual.
¡Eres un simple pulgoso! ¡Ahora fuera de aquí!
- ¡Es él, mira!
- ¡Es el niño vivo!
- ¡Está vivo!
Ya déjate de tonterías, Miguel.
Te voy a otorgar mi bendición, y volverás a casa....
¡No quiero tu bendición!
Miguel, ¡basta!
¡Regresa! ¡Miguel!
¡Estoy tratando de salvar tu vida!
- ¡Arruinas mi vida!
- ¿Qué?
La música es lo único que me hace
feliz. Y tú quieres quitarme eso.
Nunca vas a entender.
Y aunque la vida me cueste, Llorona
No dejaré de quererte...
Creí que odiabas la música.
¡Yo la adoraba! Jamás olvidé esa emoción...
cuando mi esposo tocaba yo cantaba
con él y el resto no era importante.
Pero cuando nació Coco,
encontré algo nuevo en mi vida...
con más importancia que la música.
Yo quería echar raíces.
Él quería cantar para el mundo.
Los dos hicimos sacrificios para
alcanzar nuestros deseos.
Ahora tú debes decidir.
Pero no quiero que me hagan elegir.
¿Por qué no me apoyas tú?
Eso es lo que haces las familias.
Apoyarse. Pero jamás lo harás.
- Que se diviertan.
- Oy, ¡qué emocionante!
Oh, El Santo. ¡Dios sabe como lo admiro!
Te importa si...
Gracias, Señor.
- ¿Tu invitación?
- Descuide.
Descuide. Mire, soy el tataranieto de Ernesto.
- Disculpen, señores...
- ¡Oigan! ¡Es Poco Loco!
- ¡Echabas fuego esta noche!
- ¡Igual ustedes!
Oigan, de músico a músico...
necesito un favor.
Los triunfadores de la competencia.
¡Claro que sí! Felicidades, muchachos, pasen.
¡Gracias!
- Órale, disfruta la fiesta, ¡niño músico!
- ¡Gracias!
¡Oh!
¡Miren! ¡Es Ernesto!
¡De la Cruz!
¡Señor de la Cruz!
¡Perdóneme! ¡De la Cruz!
Señor de la...
Cuando llega tu momento,
no puedes dejar que se vaya.
¡Tienes que vivirlo!
Este tiene un espíritu sabio.
Estámos cerca, Dante.
Señor de la Cruz! Señor de la--
Pero ¿qué podemos hacer? No hay esperanza.
- No pierdas la fe, hermana.
- Pero, padre, él nunca escuchará.
Él escuchará. ¡Con música!
Señoras y señores,
Buenas tardes, buenas noches
Señoritas y señores
Esta noche estar aquí
Es mi pasión, ¡qué alegría!
Pues la música es mi lengua
Y el mundo es mi familia
¿Te hiciste daño niño?
Eres tú, tu eres el muchacho, el que
proviene de la Tierra de los Vivos.
¿Tú... ya sabías de mí?
Tu eres de lo que todo el mundo ha estado
hablando. Pero ¿por qué has venido aquí?
Soy Miguel. Tu... soy tu tataranieto.
¿Yo ... tengo un tataranieto?
Necesito tu bendición. Y así
vuelvo a mi casa para ser músico...
igual que tú. El resto de nuestra
familia no quiere escuchar,
pero esperaba que tú sí.
Mi muchacho, con el talento
que tienes, ¡claro que te escucho!
¡Oigan, tengo un tataranieto!
- ¡Sí, mira! ¡Es Frida!
- Sí, soy yo. Frida Kahlo.
- Es un honor, señora.
- Gracias.
¡Ey, Negrete! ¡Infante!
¿Quieren ver a mi tataranieto?
Mi tataranieto.
¡Está vivo! ¡Y es músico también!
Se ve, no se ve. Se ve, no se ve.
¡No se ve!
Por nuestra amistad.
Yo movería el cielo y la tierra
por ti, mi amigo. ¡Salud!
¡Veneno!
¿Te dije que hice todas mis escenas de acción?
Hoy me tengo que ir mi amor
Recuérdame
Todo esto provino de mis estupendos fans
en la Tierra de los Vivos.
¡Dejan mucho más ofrendas
de las que necesito aquí!
Oye, ¿qué tienes? ¿Es demasiado?
¡Te siento abrumado!
- No, todo es in.. teresante.
- ¿Pero?
Es que... he pasado mi vida admirándote.
¡Tu lograste alcanzar tu sueño!
Pero, ¿te arrepentiste de hacerlo?
¿elegir la música en vez de lo que tenías?
Sí, fue duro. Tener que partir
de mi hogar, y salir solo al mundo.
¿Abandonando a tu familia?
Sí. Pero yo no lo cambiaría jamás.
Es inútil negar a que has venido al mundo.
Y tú, mi tataranieto,
¡has venido a volverte músico!
Tú y yo somos artistas, Miguel.
No somos de una sola familia.
El mundo es nuestra familia.
¡Los fuegos artificiales!
Pronto la fiesta se moverá cruzando el pueblo
para mi Amanecer Espectacular.
Miguel, ¿qué opinas si vienes al show?
¡Como mi invitado de honor!
- ¿De verdad?
- Por supuesto, muchacho.
No. Tengo que ir a casa
antes de que amanezca.
¡Uy! En serio tengo que regresarte.
Hijo, este fue un honor.
Lamento que tengas que irte, Miguel.
Espero que mueras muy pronto.
Tú entiendes, ¿verdad?
- Miguel, te otorgo mi bendición...
- Teníamos un trato, chamaco.
¿Quién eres tú? ¿Qué significa todo esto?
¡Frida! Dijiste que ya no vendrías.
Dijiste que llevarías mi foto.
Lo prometiste, Miguel.
¿Conoces a este hombre?
Nos conocimos hoy.
Dijo que te conocía.
¿Héctor?
Te pido, Miguel. Pon mi foto en la ofrenda.
Mi amigo, te empiezan a olvidar.
- ¿Y de quién es la culpa?
- Héctor, espera...
Eran mis canciones, Ernesto.
Mis canciones que volvieron famoso.
¿Qué?
Si me están olvidando, es porque tú jamás
le dijiste a nadie que yo las escribí.
Estás loco. De la Cruz
creó todas sus canciones.
¿Le dices tú, o le digo yo?
Héctor, no es que me quedara con el crédito,
hicimos un gran equipo, pero falleciste...
y yo solo cante tus canciones porque
quería conservar una parte de ti con vida.
¡Ay, qué generoso!
Entonces, sí tocaban juntos.
A ver, no quiero pelear por esto.
Solo quiero que enmiendes las cosas.
Miguel al fin pondrá mi foto.
y yo puedo cruzar el puente.
Estaré con mi hija. Ernesto,
¿Cómo fue la noche en que partí?
Eso fue hace un largo tiempo.
Brindé contigo. Y dijiste
que moverías el cielo y la tierra...
por tu amigo. Bien, te pido que lo hagas ahora.
¿El cielo y la tierra? ¿Igual que la película?
- ¿Qué?
- Es lo que dice Don Hidalgo.
Lo dicen en la película,
El Camino a casa.
- Yo me refiero a mi vida real, Miguel.
- ¡No! Ahí está, ¡Escucha!
Esto exige un brindis. ¡Por nuestra amistad!
Yo movería el cielo y la tierra por ti, mi amigo.
Pero en la película,
Don Hidalgo envenena el trago.
- ¡Salud!
- ¡Veneno!
Esa noche, Ernesto.
La noche en que partí...
Llevábamos de gira muchos meses.
Añoraba mi hogar. Empaqué mis canciones.
¿Te quieres marchar, estando tan cerca
de alcanzar nuestro sueño al fin?
Era tu sueño amigo, lo cumplirás.
¡Sin tus canciones no puedo hacerlo Héctor!
Me voy a casa, Ernesto.
Ódiame si quieres, pero he tomé mi decisión.
Ay, no soy capaz de odiarte. Si prefieres hacerlo,
entonces voy a despedirte con un trago.
Por nuestra amistad.
Yo movería el cielo y la tierra
por ti, mi amigo. ¡Salud!
Me acompañaste a la estación de tren.
Pero sentí un dolor en el estómago.
Pensé que debía ser algo que comí.
Tal vez fue ese chorizo, mi amigo.
O algo que... bebí.
Me desperté muerto.
Tú... me diste veneno.
Tú confundes una película
con la realidad, Héctor.
Todo este tiempo, creí que
había sido mala suerte.
Nunca imaginé que tú pudieras... Que tú...
- ¿Por qué lo hiciste?
- ¡Héctor!
¡Seguridad! ¡Seguridad!
¡Me quitaste lo que más amaba! ¡Traidor!
Debe conseguir ayuda. Él no está bien.
Solo quería volver a casa. ¡No!
Lo siento. ¿En qué me quedé?
En lo de darme tu bendición.
Sí.
Miguel, mi reputación...
Es muy importante para mí.
No me agradaría que pensaras...
¿Que envenenaste a Héctor
por sus canciones?
Tú no crees eso. ¿O sí?
Yo... No.
El bueno eres tú... eso dicen.
Papá Ernesto, ¿mi bendición?
¿Seguridad? Encárguense de Miguel.
Él va a extender su visita.
¿Qué? ¡Pero somos familia!
Y Héctor era mi mejor amigo.
El éxito no se obtiene fácil, Miguel.
Hay que estar dispuestos a hacer
lo necesario hasta vivir tu momento.
Sé que lo entiendes.
¡No!
¡Suéltenme! ¡No!
¡Ayédame! ¿Alguien puede oírme?
Quiero irme a mi casa.
-¿Héctor?
-¿Niño?
¡Héctor! Tenías razón.
Debí volver con mi familia.
No querían que fuera como de la Cruz,
pero no les hice caso.
Les dije que me daba igual si olvidaban de mi.
Que ni siquiera quería estar
en su absurda ofrenda.
Ey, chamaco. Tranquilo. Está bien.
Dije también que no los quería.
¡Héctor! ¿Héctor?
Está olvidándome.
- ¿Quién?
- Mi hijita.
Ella es la razón de que
quieras cruzar el puente.
Solo quería verla otra vez.
Hice mal en abandonar Santa Cecilia.
Quisiera decirle cómo lo siento.
Quisiera decirle que su papá sí trató de volver.
Que él la amó mucho.
Mi Coco...
¿Coco?
¿Qué? ¿De dónde la sacaste?
Ella es mi Mamá Coco.
Ella mi Mamá Imelda.
¿Y eres... tú?
Somos... ¿familia?
Siempre soñé con verla otra vez.
Que me extrañaba y...
tal vez pondría mi foto en el altar.
Pero nunca pasó.
¿Te digo qué es lo peor?
Si ya jamás veía a Coco
en el Mundo de los Vivos...
creí que al menos un día la vería aquí.
Le daría un abrazo gigante.
Pero ella es la última persona
que aún no me olvida.
En el momento que ella deje
el Mundo de los Vivos...
Tú desapareces... también de este.
... no la verás nunca.
Jamás. Así es.
De hecho escribí una canción un día.
La cantaba con ella cada noche, al mismo tiempo.
Sin importar que tan apartados estuviéramos.
Lo que daría por cantársela
una... vez... ya.
Recuérdame
Hoy me tengo que ir mi amor
No llores por favor
Te llevo en mi corazón
Y cerca me tendrás
A solas yo te cantaré
Soñando en regresar
Recuérdame
Aunque tengo que emigrar
Si mi guitarra oyes llorar
Ella con su triste canto te acompañará
Hasta que en mis brazos tú estés
Recuérdame
Se quedó tu guitarra. Y tus canciones.
Es a ti a quien el mundo no debe olvidar.
¡No a de la Cruz!
No escribí Recuérdame para al mundo.
La escribí para Coco.
Soy un pésimo intento de tatarabuelo.
¿Es un chiste? Hace un minuto creía que
tenía un asesino de pariente.
Contigo la cosa cambia.
Toda mi vida, siempre hubo algo que...
me volvía diferente.
Y no sabía de dónde venía.
Pero ahora lo sé. Esto viene de ti.
¡Qué bueno que seamos familia!
¡Estoy feliz de ser su familia!
¿Dante?
¡Dante!
¡Es Dante!
- ¡Imelda!
- Héctor.
¡Qué linda estás!
¡Dante! ¡Supiste que era mi Papá Héctor todo el tiempo!
Eres un guía espiritual.
¿Quién es el guía espiritual?
¡Tú eres!
¡Dante!
¡Miren, regresaron!
¡Miguel!
Mijo, ¡estaba angustiada!
¡Qué gusto que te hallamos a tiempo!
Y tú...
¿cuántas veces voy a tener que rechazarte?
Imelda.
¡No quiero tener nada contigo!
¡Ni en vida, ni en muerte!
Yo pasé décadas protegiendo a mi familia
de tus errores.
Él pasa cinco minutos contigo
¡y tengo que salvarlo de un agujero!
Héctor no hizo que cayera.
Él entró ahí por mí.
¡Solo trató de regresarme a casa!
Yo no quise escucharlo, pero él tenía razón.
Nada es más importante que la familia.
Esta vez sí aceptaré tu bendición.
Y tus condiciones. Pero antes,
tengo que buscar a de la Cruz.
Y quitarle la foto de Héctor.
- ¿Qué?
- Para que se encuentre con Coco allá.
Héctor debe estar en la ofrenda.
Es parte de la familia.
¡Abandonó a su familia!
Trató de volver contigo y con Coco,
¡Pero de la Cruz lo envenenó!
- Es cierto, Imelda.
- ¿Y qué si eso es verdad?
Huyes y me dejas con una niña que cuidar...
¿y de pronto esperas que te perdone?
Imelda, yo...
¡Héctor!
No me queda tanto tiempo. Es Coco.
Te está olvidando.
Tú tal vez no lo perdones.
Pero no hay que olvidarlo.
Yo sí quería olvidarte.
Quería que Coco también te olvidara, pero...
Es culpa mía. No tuya.
Perdóname, Imelda.
Miguel, si te ayudamos a buscar
su foto, ¿regresarás a casa?
¿No más música?
La familia es primero.
Yo... no te perdono.
Pero voy a salvarte.
Hay que llegar a de la Cruz.
¿Qué hay que hacer?
Tal vez, yo sé.
- Suerte, muchacho.
- Gracias, Frida.
- Déjame ayudarte con...
- ¡Sin tocarme!
- ¿Todos recuerden el plan?
- Buscar la foto de Héctor.
- Dársela a Miguel.
- Enviar a Miguel casa.
¿Tienen sus pétalos?
Ahora, solo hay que buscar a de la Cruz.
¿Sí?
¿No te conozco?
¡Es por acabar con el amor de mi vida!
- ¿Qué... de quién?
- ¡Ella se refiere a mí!
- ¿Soy el amor de tu vida?
- No lo sé. Sigo furiosa contigo.
¡Héctor! ¿De dónde...?
Y esto es por tratar de acabar con mi nieto.
- ¿Nieto?
- ¡Ella está hablando de mí!
¡Tú! Alto. ¿Eres nieto de Héctor?
¡La foto!
¡Atrápenlo!
¡Seguridad! ¡Ayúdenme!
- Dijiste "amor de tu vida".
- Ay, ya no sé lo que dije.
Yo lo escuché.
Ah sí, señor. Dale 30 segundos.
¡Ay! ¡Miguel! ¡La tengo!
¡Apúrate! ¡Rápido!
Damas y caballeros...
el grande... el único...
¡Ernesto de la Cruz!
Sáquenla de ahí.
¡Canta! ¡Canta!
Ay, de mi Llorona
Llorona de azul celeste
Y aunque la vida me cueste, Llorona
No dejaré de quererte
Me subí al pino más alto, Llorona
A ver si te divisaba
Como el pino era tierno, Llorona
Al verme llorar, lloraba
Ay de mí Llorona, Llorona
Llorona de azul celeste
Y aunque la vida me cueste, Llorona
No dejaré de quererte
- ¡Suéltame!
- Y aunque la vida me cueste, Llorona
No dejaré de quererte
Ay, ay, ay
Ay, olvidé cómo se sentía.
Tú aún lo tienes.
Miguel, te otorgo mi bendición.
Para ir a casa,
poner nuestras fotos y nunca más...
nunca más volver a tocar música.
y nunca más olvides lo mucho que tu familia te ama.
Irás a casa.
No irás a ningún lado.
¡Imelda!
Todos atrás. ¡Apártense! Les advierto,
.... No den un paso más.
¡Dante!
Ernesto, ¡espera!
Deja en paz al niño.
Trabajé muy duro, Héctor.
No puedo dejar que destruya todo.
Es un niño vivo, Ernesto.
¡Es una amenaza!
¿Crees que lo dejaré volver
a la Tierra de los Vivos con tu foto?
¿Y conservar tu memoria con vida? No.
- ¡Eres un cobarde!
- Soy Ernesto de la Cruz.
¡El mejor músico de todos los tiempos!
Héctor es el verdadero músico.
¡Tú eres el hombre que lo asesinó
y robó sus canciones!
¿Cómo dijo?
Yo soy un hombre dispuesto a lo que sea
para vivir mi momento.
No importa que sea.
¡No!
¡Miguel!
Disculpa, querido amigo.
Pero el show debe continuar.
... mi familia.
¡Asesino!
Orquesta. Uno, dos, ...
Recuérdame
Hoy me tengo que...
¡Miren!
Gatito.
¡Bájame! ... ¡No!
¡No!
¿Algo que no vi?
¡Buen perro, Dante!
¡Miguel!
¡Héctor! La foto... ¡no la tengo!
Descuida, mijo. Está...
¡Héctor! ¿Héctor?
Coco.
¡No! Encontraremos la foto.
Miguel, casi amanece ya.
No, no. No te vayas.
Te prometí que pondría tu foto en la ofrenda.
Te prometí que verías a Coco.
Se acaba nuestro tiempo, mijo.
¡Ay, no! ¡No! ¡No dejé que ella te olvide!
Solo quería decirle cuanto la amé.
- ¡Héctor!
- Ten nuestra bendición, Miguel.
Sin condiciones.
¡No! Papá Héctor, ¡espera!
¡No!
- Ve a casa.
- Yo prometo. ¡No dejaré que Coco te olvide!
¡Ahí está!
¡Miguel! ¡Alto!
- ¿Dónde estuviste?
- Tengo que ver a Mamá Coco, pronto.
¿Qué haces con esa...? ¡Dámela!
Miguel, ¡detente! ¡Miguel!
¿Mamá Coco? Escúchame. Soy Miguel.
Conocí a tu papá. ¿Tu papá? ¿Papá?
¡Por favor! Si lo olvidas,
desaparecerá. Para siempre.
Miguel, ¡abre la puerta!
Esta era su guitarra, ¿sí?
Él la tocaba para ti.
Sí, ¡ahí está! Recuerda tu papá. ¿Papá?
- ¡Miguel!
- Mamá Coco, ¡mira! No lo vayas a olvidar.
¿Qué le haces a esta pobre mujer?
Tranquila, mamita.
¿Y ahora qué te pasa?
Creí que te perdí....
Perdóname, papá.
Estamos juntos ahora.
Eso es lo que importa.
No estamos todos.
Tranquila, mamita.
Miguel, discúlpate con tu Mamá Coco.
¿Mamá Coco?
¿Y bien? ¡Discúlpate!
Tu papá, él quería que tuvieras esto.
Mamá, ¡espera!
Recuérdame
Hoy me tengo que ir mi amor
No llores por favor
Te llevo en mi corazón
Y cerca me tendrás
A solas yo te cantaré
Soñando en regresar
Recuérdame
Aunque tengo que emigrar
Si mi guitarra oyes llorar
Ella con su triste canto te acompañará
Hasta que en mis brazos tú estés
Recuérdame
¿Elena? ¿Qué tienes, mija?
Nada, mamá. No tengo nada.
Mi papá me cantaba esa canción.
Él te amaba, Mamá Coco.
Tu papá te amaba muchísimo.
Conservé sus cartas...
poemas que me escribió. Y...
Papá era músico.
Cuando yo era una niña...
él y mamá cantaban las más bellas canciones.
Y por este lado está uno de los
más grandes tesoros de Santa Cecilia.
El hogar del estimado compositor Héctor Rivera.
Las cartas que Héctor enviaba a su hija, Coco ...
contienen las letras de todas sus piezas
favoritas. No solo Recuérdame.
Y ese hombre es tu Papá Julio.
Ella es la tía Rosita y tu tía Victoria.
Y ellos dos son Oscar y Felipe.
No solo son antiguas fotos,
son nuestra familia...
y cuentan con nosotros para no olvidarlos.
Dirás que es raro
Lo que me pasó
Disfruta tu visita, Héctor.
Parece que anoche
Te encontré en mis sueños
-¡Papá!
-¡Coco!
Las palabras que dije
Se volvieron canción
Versos que tuyos son
Y el recuerdo nos dio
Una melodía bella
Que el alma tocó
Con el ritmo que vibra
En nuestro interior
Amor verdadero
Nos une por siempre
En el latido de mi corazón
Amor verdadero
Nos une por siempre
En el latido de mi corazón
Ay mi familia
Oiga mi gente
Canten a coro
Nuestra canción
Amor verdadero
Nos une por siempre
En el latido de mi corazón
Ay mi familia
Oiga mi gente
Canten a coro
Nuestra canción
Amor verdadero
Nos une por siempre
En el latido de mi corazón